they're not going to post mucus up in
there yeah man
okay so millie bobby brown uh posted
on her instagram story i think it was
yesterday or maybe two days ago
what happened you know that keep going
yeah yeah i don't know
she's like in a car and she talks about
how she was just out shopping with her
mom
and a fan comes up to her she doesn't
say like how old the fan is but she says
it's a woman who came up to her
saying hi are you such and such she says
yes
and she the fan then proceeds to ask her
can i take a video of you
and she thought that it was going to be
a photo or video with her but she's like
no
no like you just doing whatever it is
you're doing and i'm just going to video
you while you're in the
store that is weird and millie bobby
brown goes ahead and says like no i'm
not really comfortable with that i'm
with my mom right now we're just trying
to get some christmas shopping done
and this woman proceeds to kind of
follow her around the store
recording her and she turns around says
like oh can you please stop
she says i'm a human yeah she says i'm a
human this is disrespectful
what does her mom do during i don't know
she doesn't really say what her mom did
i would've tried so she ended up
uh leaving she gets in the car does the
or instagram [ __ ] right i don't know i
think she deleted one of her
social media apps she's also a 16 year
old girl that's the thing like if i'm
the mom
i go like a child the mom didn't say
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying
about it it's on the mom to do it but
also but also
like celebrities have dealt with way
worse than this
like girl you're just getting started
right this is bad
tom cruise had some [ __ ] break into his
house and film she doesn't have that
perspective being sick
with his tingling
there are recorded stories and
situations of her ever since she got
onto stranger things of like
older people dming her [ __ ] because she
was a star as a kid yeah i mean
are you accusing drake right now
this is [ __ ] when you make a video
about it i was
um an animal and i said you know yes
and she said can i take a video of you
i said um no
but why would anyone want to be taking a
video of
of me you know like like it's not like
the both of us like of me
at the end of the day i don't need to
justify it to anyone if i don't want to
be taking a video of i don't i don't
have to be
and um i was paying and she walked past
me
and began to video me again and i said
i'm a human being
like what what more do what more can i
ask from you
i asked her i asked her she said so i
can't take a video of a human being
and i said no no when i said no it just
makes me upset
when people try and push the boundary
and i just wish people were more
respectful still trying to navigate this
all
and it's still overwhelming i will take
a picture with you
but when you push the boundary and you
try and fight me on it
there are my rights to say no i'm making
this video to say
you you have to show more respect for
others no matter who they are
what they do show respect human
being to human being it's it's just
matter
i respect that no matter no matter you
say it's cut up though it's weird what
more it's because it's just
you don't need to cry but she's young
right you know like that yeah you don't
need to make a video about it even
yeah it's an incident that you could
have if you were older you go that that
person's gross
and they're shitty but water off the
back like if
if you say no can you put that
[ __ ] in the headlock no well
she's doing she's like
she's gonna go really you can if i was
her i'm like man this is [ __ ]
terrible not go to my bank account like
damn that shit's dope
right that's the thing she's that would
be my dad like damn that [ __ ] was great
she's yeah that's true she is young so
that's the one thing that's like
her brain so you know i do a 16 what
would you do i'd look at my bank and i'm
like
and then at 16 i would jump in my
[ __ ] ferrari from stranger things
three and [ __ ] drive home i i get
where you're coming from
but i remember myself at 16. yeah and i
would have had it if i'm her
and she probably does okay i would have
an ego
out the ass yeah and i'd be like have
you heard the stories on her
no i know that yes really nightmare
she didn't get along with the other kids
why not she's way more famous
she's 11. she's 11. you talk about finn
you're talking about you talking about
the the kid who was the wolf gang the
guy who's going to actually
yeah the other kid went on it and stuff
he's big yeah yeah yeah he's one kid's
[ __ ]
finn wolf gang or whatever i forget his
name no the black kid's the worst you
come out on it
worst actor of all time in a major movie
what's his name finn wolfhard not the
card i was close he's a big deal he's
big he's blown up yeah actually [ __ ] so
they say on set
she's a bit of a diva since she's coming
is she the star big time you've never
seen stranger things oh
okay i saw i gave up you've seen
stranger things one two or three
hell no i stopped in two you guys
started living you stop start living i'm
not living because i'm watching the
right dog
stranger things i think it's white
people [ __ ]
oh okay maybe no you would like it
you love the music do you like the music
music soundtrack's fantastic
like sciency like it's retro it's like
you like
aliens yeah that might not be let me ask
you this do you like dope [ __ ]
yeah and you would love stranger things
do you like back to the future and like
retro [ __ ]
no i didn't get it um yeah like i just
don't think it's or chappelle
i bet you dig it because it's like 80. i
don't know i don't like alien [ __ ]
for you tonight i don't watch a [ __ ]
night it's more it's more
it's more uh 80s than it is aliens it's
not even aliens it's like the female
ultra it feels so dope it's so well done
the original thick boy hopper's on there
hopper he's a state trooper right
yeah it's great it's like a sheriff or
something yeah it's a great show
sometimes you forget she's 16 when she's
[ __ ] around with drake you know the
drake thing's weird wait what happened
drake's bobby brown talked about how
uh she and drake text often and he gives
her
advice about boys and she was like maybe
fifteen fourteen doesn't drink
everything
what was that doctor earlier
he's probably like this is how you
should deal with it but i don't have a
history of this drake's [ __ ]
rihanna and all these gorgeous women
she's [ __ ]
asap rocky now yeah we don't know her
[Music]
see what they said they had a cool
little room how many did i grab
it's fine do you want some josh i'm good
on that [ __ ]
you don't have a sweet tooth no not at
all i'm more this is so crazy
for more booze before oh they're just
nice if you want more let me know yeah
i'm down yeah they're saying that
they have like a friend yeah so her
parents know who drake is and [ __ ]
yeah it's like a weird situation i don't
think it's that weird you don't think
it's weird
no it's he's so famous and as far as i
know the dm's are pretty harmless him
being like hey
navigate this way like he's thinking
about he's more famous
plus she was he was famous when he was
her age yeah that's right so maybe
yeah he was on like the grass so to me i
feel like he's just navigating like hey
do this dude don't do that be careful of
this i love you so much though something
like that
yeah that's weird you know that's weird
there's some things you could probably
take out of it and go like this is weird
it's text messages you know like
yeah i'm finding this with twitter as my
audience grows
people will like if you just reply to
somebody people like you don't need to
get defensive
and you're like i'm just replying to
your dog like i'm not getting defensive
yeah it's
literally writing exactly i get in
trouble with text too because my text
will be so harsh but it's like it's text
i'm just talking there's no context
i'm yeah i'm just talking and you're
just like you know people like they have
they take wild um what's the word like
uh
assumptions assumptions yeah damn dog
that's fine it's all good
yeah it's all good that's what i used to
say too how about that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son